let's go next to our caller from the
4:01 area code who's calling today from
4:01
hey David it's Dave hey Dave what's up
I'm uh I understand that the electoral
college is uh
there to stop certain faction or
demographic whatever from ruling and
definitely sure but it seems as though
it's working it against its purpose my
question is do you think the Electoral
College will rather be done away with
what would the process be and how come
there seems to be plenty of talk about
it and no action I'm from Rhode Island
which by the way Bernie
listen so you're completely right the
Electoral College in it one of the main
priorities of it was we don't want all
of the rural areas being ignored and
having candidates mass at cities and
only paying attention to them but what
we have in practice is that the
candidates are just paying attention to
these Keir lee states and states that
are strategically significant it's still
ignoring a whole bunch of different
people and quite frankly with modern
media I don't really care where the
candidate goes I don't care if a can
that it comes to Boston or not they're
better than Donald Trump I'm going to
vote for them right so I think that
you're right in your analysis the bet
the most of the simplest path to
removing the electoral college is the
national popular vote interstate compact
you can basically just do it at the
state level if you get enough states
whose electoral votes total 270 to
decide we will award our electoral votes
not to the winner in our state but to
the winner of the National popular vote
you effectively create a national
popular vote doesn't require
ratification by by States doesn't
require a vote in the House and Senate
that for me is the most direct path to
it so that someone basically it has to
be like within the 50 states like a
statewide coalition or something to to
go to the governor and say well we want
the popular vote not
the electoral road this is well you
basically say some states have done it
Dave and you the state would say okay so
normally the way a state Awards
electoral votes is if a candidate wins
Massachusetts Massachusetts gives their
electoral votes to that candidate
Massachusetts can decide will vote but
we aren't going to give the votes the
electoral votes to the winner of our
state we're going to give the votes to
the winner of the popular vote
nationally to get the delegates room
will choose that or whatever that guess
that we can or quit so you have to get
the governor whoever's inside of that
Secretary of State to like go to them
with a almost kind of like a petition it
can be the state in a state election
ballot initiative okay I got you
and uh side question like how come there
isn't there like states like you know
North Dakota or something with no zero
population has more electoral votes then
like a more populated smaller state like
why is that do a thing yeah so it is why
that smaller state because of how the
the electoral votes are apportioned
smaller states don't have more votes but
they have disproportionately more
relative to their populations that is
true and that's another one of the
problems with our system seems like the
the deck is stacked there's yes
absolutely absolutely Dave from Rhode
Island thank you so much for the call I
appreciate the call